it's really difficult to get your first
feature as a director off the ground but
it could be just as hard to get the
second one off the ground too even if
your first one got a whole lot of
Academy Award love so what would you say
is one big misconception about what it
means to make your second feature but
then on the other hand what is something
about promising young woman that really
did help you get Sal saltburn off the
ground and made the way you wanted God
that's an incred ibly difficult question
to answer but I love it but I love it um
so I think the thing the the thing that
is what promising a woman did and what
the incredible success that truly like
none of us could have ever expected did
was it enabled me to do the thing to
have the process which
I can only really do which is to go away
not tell anyone what I'm working on not
show anyone anything at all not talk
about it
I write it and then I give it to you
know my managers and agents and say this
is the thing that I want to make if
anyone else wants to make it incredible
you know and if not that's fine we can
find something else and so I think what
it does is it means that you don't end
up in that very sticky place which lots
of filmmakers I think can get caught up
in which is that thing of development
everyone loves an idea they think it's
really sexy then you deliver the script
and they're like a I thought it was
going to be something different because
when you pitched it in the room and like
oh I always imagined this actor in it
not this actor you know the thing is is
that what happens then is you are kind
of making something by committee and
obviously the moment you start casting
the moment you start being in prep and
all of that kind of stuff you become it
becomes completely egalitarian it it you
have every you desire you need
everyone's input that's what's so
wonderful it is a group effort making a
movie but I think the writing of it and
the kind of you know the the sort of
the conceiving of the thing that you
want to make in all of the different
ways has to be completely solitary for
me and so that process meant it
was that process enabled me to make the
thing I wanted to make next I think if
IID pitched this movie in all of its
kind of gory detail people would have
said yes but maybe we could change this
you know it minimizes the the
interference
I think I am so glad you made this movie
the exact way you wanted cuz I can't
imagine it any other way thank you thank
you so much so bringing up the uh the
collaborative nature once you do wind up
hitting the set it does make me wonder
what would you say is the biggest
difference between draft one of this
screenplay and what we will now see in
the finished film oh that's so
interesting H you know I try to be
pretty close try to be pretty close to
the draft I'm quite a stickler um but I
think
that I think that once the actors come
in the connection and the love becomes
more apparent you know they add they
they add a huge amount of I think what
we worked on a lot in the you know once
they all came on board was why they love
each other even if we're talking about
people who are not capable of or good at
showing love I mean there's no one in
this film who actually knows how to
communicate love effectively or in a
healthy way so so much of our work then
was was in the kind of in the Deep parts
of why they love each other and what it
feels like to love people and and how
that is complicated and I think that
really you really feel that that in the
movie oh I can't wait to jump to your
Ensemble but first I do have a question
that I wanted to ask based on another
interview I heard you had done where you
mentioned that along the way there were
some other characters that fell by the
wayside yeah can you share anything
about one of those characters it's so
funny isn't it because you sort of like
all of those people got slaughtered for
a reason they all got booted off a cliff
for a reason I think that there was more
stuff at Oxford initially so there was
more Michael gavy who was oliv's sort of
friend who gets immediately like cul
once he gets better offer um there were
also some more of the what I would call
the
like the collateral damage of the Katen
family so we had a few
more we we there was there was a there
was a moment with one of the boys from
the past one of the former
favorites uh but you know it's difficult
with this film because there are so many
charact it's actually really really is a
kind of Ensemble and
the the problem is is the more people
you have the less time you then spend on
the people that you really love and need
to know so so there you know I mean
there were so many there there's a world
where this film could have been like 20
hours long and and had been you know I
mean poor dear Pamela and elath alone
could be their own film I would watch
that really long version of this film
but also it's nice to know that that
world and that experience exists or be
convinced that it exists based on this
shorter more contained version of the
story that we do get yes all right
jumping back to your Ensemble actually
first a directing actors's question for
you yet again another big old compound
question what is something that another
director did for you in the past that
you appreciated and always strive to do
for your actors when you're directing
but then on the other hand what is
something that you wished more actors
directors had done for you that now you
always make sure your cast has oh that's
a really good question I think so I
think cha button who is an incredible
director who directed a film called
visra in Virginia that I was in is an is
an absolute expert at running a
trust-based
warm set you know she makes sure she has
time for everyone she's incredibly
inspiring she's Resolute but kind I
think that she's so inspiring when it
comes to
just yeah kind of creating the kind of
atmosphere that means people can play
and that's something that's so important
to me to to have you know to to make a
space sound so kind of twe and cheesy
but to make a space where people feel
that they can like make mistakes where
they feel that they can come to you with
an idea that is outlandish and that
you're they're not going to be like
crucified for it she was so inspiring
that regard also Joe Wright I have to
say you know he is so specific about
what he wants in a way that I find
really gra that I really responded to as
an act as an actor what I liked was the
detail what I liked was the Precision
what I liked was almost you are kind of
a he tells you exactly he has an exact
thing in his mind and it's and it's
there something so like wonderful about
being giving yourself over to that kind
of process giving yourself over to
someone for them to tell you exactly
what they want that's that I found very
like um interesting and kind of
inspiring and then you know I think
truly the thing that I hated most as an
actress was the sense that there was a
ation going on by the monitor that
wasn't coming to me that the that in the
walk between video Village to me
something was being
sugarcoated and I just hate it hate it
hate it it made me feel gross and
insecure and freaked out and like a baby
and so the thing that I always do when I
kind of like talk to actors even before
we're like getting into it is say like
is established how like honest we can be
with each other it's not to say that
I'll Ever Be Cruel but uh and and that
runs both ways it's that it's actually
it's the opposite it's like we're all in
this together from the beginning there
are no nice trailers everyone has the
same shitty two-way nobody goes back to
base for changes there's a makeup
station onset there's a green room onset
whether you've got one line or you're
the star that's where you hang out we
all Le Together cast and crew there are
you know I it is very very important to
me that everyone understands that we are
in this together and we all able to be
as honest with each other we're not
going to [__] foot around each other
and when you're making a film that is
you know as complicated and sticky and
exposing as this film is for all of us
you know not least the actors you have
got to trust each other and you've also
got to trust that your boundaries will
be respected too that's a big big thing
for me like we had an amazing intimacy
coordinator
and it meant that all of us felt so much
more
comfortable just talking about stuff and
you know it's just it's just treating
everyone like grown-ups and expecting
that that you yourself will be treated
like a grown-up too like there is
nothing in the world that makes me more
impatient than the sense I'm being
managed it it makes me insane and it's
designed to make you insane it's that
simple I don't understand why every
single person at the uh at the helm of a
film does not lead their company that
way because a lot of them
are not concerned
with with that it does
if you're not concerned with that you're
not you're not concerned about the
quality of your film overall because
ultimately that trickles down and it
breaks my heart to think about a film
being ruined that way well and but also
I think the thing that's really
important is it's not just a kind of
basic level of human decency and care
it's not to say I'm perfect by the way
like you know we all have our
moments but it's actually just bad
business because the truth of it is is
if you're all happy and you all love
each other and you respect each other
you do work that is better
and more interesting and more difficult
you know I've no interest in making
something I want to make something
complicated I want to make something
messy and difficult that people argue
about and that you
know that isn't going to necessarily be
like the most easy to sort of pin down
thing and in order to make something
like that you've got to yeah you you
have to create a very specific kind of
environment a beautiful answer and
beautiful approach I want to squeeze in
one or two spoiler questions before I do
that just to briefly touch on what could
come next from you because I love horror
movies and I see a very like
intoxicating Darkness now in both of the
films that you've made so it is leaving
me wondering is a full-fledged horror
movie in your future definitely I mean I
don't know that it will necessarily be
the next thing but I am a horror Fiend I
think horror is the greatest it's the
greatest and and so and it's so exciting
now that horror movies seem to be
getting their kind of just you know they
seem to be getting their just desserts
right they're getting their due horror
is yeah it's one of the first it was one
of the first movie mediums right horror
and romance the gothic that's what
movies were made to do so yeah
absolutely I hope so one day I also
heard you're a big fan of Are You Afraid
of the Dark and so that left me
wondering what is your favorite are you
afid of the dark episode I think it's
everyone's favorite it's Melissa
jonart I'm cold it's the boy standing
outside her window saying I'm cold and
the twist is that it's a boy who died
because he didn't have his sweater and
it was in a log and I was like how can I
be both so terrified of this but also so
moved by Sabrina the Teenage Witch I
hear that one a lot I love tale of the
Midnight Madness the nose Fatu inspired
one remember that it's so good it was a
Gateway horror experience where I had to
know what inspired it after did you have
the game did you have the PC game I want
I need that game I need to play that
game again because the music still gives
me chills I can still think about that
game all the time the eyeballs having to
do I mean that game was insanely
frightening for a tiny child that was my
world for a really really long time I
could talk about Are You Afraid of the
Dark all day long they're going to kick
out in a minute so I'm going to try to
squeeze in one or two spoiler questions
first this is more of a theory question
have you ever wondered how things might
have progressed if Felix never took
Oliver back home and learned the truth
about his family yes all the time
because would have happened next was it
inevitable that eventually they would
wind up I think C I think I mean
certainly the thing is is I can't answer
those questions because so necessarily
the film leaves those things unresolved
but I think you probably know you know
that's the thing we we're only we're all
just reacting in the moment no matter
how like you know no matter how
meticulously we planned things it was
the same with promising young woman we
are not in control of the way that other
people behave we can't be and so we have
to react to that but you know it is a
love story it should have been a love
story that breaks my heart when you put
it that way I'll ask one question about
working with Barry now which scene of
the bunch was most challenging to
calibrate in terms of making sure his
performance had the right balance of you
know being truly who that character is
but also who he's presenting himself to
be in the moment I think it's all the
early stuff at Oxford you know the sort
of it's uh um particularly the kind of
like you know the the S when the moment
that Felix feels that he's pulling away
and Oliver intensifies his kind of
madeup story I think the thing for me is
that we know from the very beginning of
this movie from the framing narrative
what's going to happen we know who he is
already you know there's no surprises
there the one surprise I was really the
only surprise I was really hoping to
kind of keep was was who Oliver's family
are the rest of it we we know we just
don't know exactly how we get a s we
just don't know exactly how or what
necessarily but that that was important
to me cuz that should feel as
devastating for us as it feels for him
the moment that we know what's happening
and Felix hasn't clocked it yet and he's
like this is nice
mate I love it so much he's perfect and
that your whole ensemble hair is perfect
I can't I've only seen it once at this
point I can't wait to go back and watch
it again knowing every single thing that
happened so that I could track all these
little things that I probably missed the
first time around also because I saw a
fantastic best and the audience there
was eating it up oh yay well it's made
for an audience you know people squiring
it's the best great success based on the
one viewing I've had thus far and I have
a feeling everyone's doing that thank
you for your time today congratulations
thanks Perry thank
you